at the end of time
[Music]
[Applause]
13 o'clock
hey everybody what's going on hopefully
yeah okay the microphone's on because I
was gonna well I always gotta check now
because
you never know sometimes it just turns
itself off like randomly for whatever
reason [__] ghosts they get mad
because we talk about them on a haunting
Monday
I guess so so today we're going to be
talking about some CIA stuff
CIA stuff so you know dirty [__] they
would they say so so if we end up
murdered yeah uh or suicided or
something like that you'll you'll know
what happened they find us [__] with
us hung suicide and shot and our throats
cut all suicide yeah
[Laughter]
the this was actually I didn't know a
great deal about this case um one of you
got actually a couple of you guys
recommended it
um you know obviously I had heard about
the um the whole Contra controversy and
like you know the CIA knowing about drug
running and uh you know drug trafficking
and stuff and I kind of knew about that
because I remember when that was going
on like in the 1980s but I hadn't really
heard that much about Gary Webb who was
the investigative journalist who he
wasn't the first one to break the story
because the story actually did break in
the 80s but nobody really picked up on
it he was just kind of the one that you
know picked up the torch like a decade
later and then there was like a huge
controversy but um
he's kind of like an interesting figure
like I said he sadly passed away now but
I was watching uh if you look around on
YouTube there's not a [__] ton of stuff
about him but there is um some stuff
from like the hearings back in that time
like when they investigated the the
allegations that he made and I also
found a uh somebody recorded him talking
like at a book store in at in Berkeley
like right after like in 1998 I think it
was like right after his book came out
and um so that was like really cool it
was like almost an hour long so I like
listened to that on my lunch hour today
so it was kind of cool to like listen to
him
talk about his own books and like talk
about the allegations and talk about
like the [__] show that ensued like
after they published it because it was
kind of like uh pretty shitty like what
happened to him you know what I mean
yeah
but uh yeah murder Hornet said I
remember the Oliver North trial as a kid
yeah I do too like I think I was
probably I wasn't young young but I was
kind of like too young to really know
like all the
intricacies of what was going on and I
have to say that this is I mean I tried
to do like a lot of research about this
case but it's like it's very complicated
so I'm gonna try and kind of keep it
fairly simple
um I have like three different sets of
notes to like because I was just kind of
like well I had this set and I was like
well I don't know that didn't really
cover like everything I wanted to cover
and then like I have so I kind of just
printed them all out and I just have
them at different places so if I'm like
if I'm ferreting around like looking for
stuff like looking for people's names
and [__] like that yeah it's gonna be a
good show well this was like yeah like I
said this was really interesting and you
know it's I kind of feel like the whole
the whole uh Contra drug war thing
that's kind of like a whole like massive
huge topic
um I do want to kind of stick more with
Gary Webb but we can kind of talk about
and like what happened to him and stuff
but
um you know obviously we have to give
context so we have to talk about and I
know that a lot of our listeners are not
from the United States so they might and
maybe weren't alive back in the 1980s so
um so maybe they don't remember like all
of these allegations that came out like
about the CIA and as I said it's kind of
sad that Gary Webb got sort of
I don't know if I'd necessarily go so
far as to say he was hounded out of the
profession because he did still you know
he did still work as an investigative
journalist but for sure
um he kind of his career was kind of
ruined you know what I mean like yeah
yeah
um and you know obviously whether it was
suicide or murder
um you know he he was for sure really
um depressed and really upset about the
[__] that happened to him so I wouldn't
be surprised if it was murder but the
way he or suicide but the way he died
was a little bit weird so all you big
powerful countries have intelligence
agencies they're they're dirty all right
they also have like Counter Intelligence
people involved in that so somebody's
investigating them they're going to say
well that's a spy or they don't care if
it's a spy or not okay just anybody
investigating what they do they're gonna
[__] send counterintelligence after
him which is contractors you know that
do [__] like prank call you [__] 24 7
they can find your phone number no
matter how many times you change it they
were doing that back in the 80s
stalking people by phone
um hounding them at their house just
terrifying them you know and then in in
the person would never see him
you know if I can pick up the phone and
it sounds like you know rabbits
screaming and stuff for children
screaming that kind of stuff and they
don't know in one case that I remember
just off the top of my head I think it
was Israeli counterintelligence doing it
to a guy oh because he was investigating
something Israel was doing
when he was in the United States
could have been it could have been CIA
though they probably could maybe maybe
they were involved with you know because
they're involved with intelligence
agents agencies in uh in Israel they
work together so it could be that they
just covering their friends back the CIA
was
you say CIA that's kind of a vague term
there's a lot of compartments in it they
hire people to do stuff
yeah and that's the thing and I kind of
feel like and I was thinking about this
while I was reading about the case it's
like you know it's very easy to say
something like oh the CIA did this and
that the other thing but it's like the
CIA is a massive yeah organization and
it's like dude I work in an office with
like 19 other people it's like I don't
know what the person in the next office
is doing like much less somebody like
way across the [__] country or like
you know in another country or something
like that so you can't just like lay
[__] on the like the whole thing because
like you said it's very
compartmentalized yeah and
the guys that actually do stuff
in the real world they don't a lot of
times they're doing stuff and they don't
know that they're doing it for the CIA
you know CIA owns companies and you know
front companies
that do stuff and uh you know they may
not be a paramilitary company they might
be like
a faction inside the telephone company
you know it might be Sprint or something
and they got people inside Sprint
working and they can just you know Trace
any kind of calls anywhere you know or
they're looking for certain people and
they're working in then other ones are
just fake companies that they can just
open up
for a few years and then close it and it
would vanish but while it was open it
was doing something doing something
Shady
and the guys that were in it maybe most
of them probably didn't know
what they were doing or who they were
working for
you know just kind of like innocent
people
yeah that's that's kind of the thing I
do feel like that's why and I think I've
said this before but that's why I don't
have a problem believing in like small
conspiracy theories where it's just like
a handful of people like you know
maneuvered and did some [__] but the
bigger the conspiracy gets the less I
believe in it because there's just too
many
moving parts and the thing about it is
that like you said it could be just for
you know for just for a random example
that it's like somebody gets recruited
into something like going to work for a
company or something they're doing all
this stuff and it's like a front for the
CIA and they don't [__] know that
yeah that's a conspiracy Yeah well yeah
yeah no I'm not saying that but I'm just
saying that it's like I I kind of feel
like conspiracies are work better when
they're more like localized like that uh
you know I worked I worked for a company
that
did [__] trained people from all over
the world police and stuff
and you're not really sure who the
students are
the the client was the state department
of State all right
but everybody working in there is a
civilian
you know not really sure what you're
doing you're just doing what you're told
you're just running ranges and doing
courses and classrooms they got guys
cleaning classrooms and
cops and soldiers and stuff from all
over the world are coming in there to do
these
post-blast investigation courses and
this is a private company
that's not the government
all right so yeah that's a conspiracy
hell yeah and that and that that
particular company's gone
I've looked for it online it's just gone
and it was around for about seven years
so don't tell me that a conspiracy can't
be big though they can be very funny no
that's not what I said okay that's what
I was thinking you were saying no no it
can be very big like the Manhattan
Project was [__] huge and most people
involved it didn't know what it was but
that's what I'm saying it's like I'm
saying that when you get into these
things where people talk about this
conspiracy theories where like all these
people have to know about all this kind
of no I don't know I don't yeah I don't
I don't think that's the case that's
that's what I mean when I say that like
the bigger it gets like the less it's no
you know what I mean well you can have
four or five companies working together
and only the guys that are directing the
company nobody else knows
nobody else knows what what they're
really doing
because it's all only the guys that have
a need to know basis sort of you know
and they're taking orders from
I don't want to say
government people because that those
guys are kind of like mid-level
functionaries the guys who really run
the [__] are basically oligarchs
captains of industry you know the robber
barons that you heard about you know in
the early 1900s that built the United
States they won they didn't lose they
won they just they're just invisible now
they own all this and control that it
all works for them
Camp guy said I've always heard this
about the CIA and cocaine yeah and the
thing about it is that even though they
swore up and down back then
that they knew absolutely nothing about
it uh they did actually kind of come out
later and go yeah we did gonna know
about it I'm not gonna go so far as well
because I think one of the main
criticisms of Gary Webb's uh series that
he wrote which was called Dark Alliance
we'll get into that a little bit but was
that I think that people thought that he
was implying I don't think he said this
outright and like when I watched him do
a talk like at Berkeley he actually said
out right that he didn't think this was
the case he's like I don't think it's
the case that the CIA because like you
know a lot of people like um
particularly back then in the 80s and
90s like in South Central and stuff they
thought that the CI was purposely
flooding the streets of South Central
Los Angeles with crack in order to [__]
over black people
um I don't necessarily I can see why
they would believe that
um I don't necessarily think that's the
case I think what probably happened was
that the CIA was kind of like
involved with I think they more kind of
turned a blind eye to it or we're just
kind of like we're just gonna let that
guy do that more than like doing it on
you know what I mean here's another way
to look at it
if you're a government agency that has a
mission
and you're trying to keep this Mission
Secret
the last thing you want is your budget
to be exposed you know before Congress
or anything else you can tell what it
what a unit is doing by how it's
spending money
drug money's cash and it's untraceable
that's that's a black budget right there
so if you're an intelligent intelligence
agency that has connections and Ways and
Means and ways to make money through the
sales of drugs not you directly but
you're hiring contractors to do it right
okay this is the big deal this is this
is the thing they don't actually do it
it's three or four steps down yeah so
they can have plausible there's all
kinds of plausible deniability now money
can flow to them and the drug dealers
and everything and and and even the
Smugglers can make their cut
but at the top it's flowing up into the
into an intelligence agency and uh
that's invisible money that can be used
to do some kind of mission or to buy a
swim pool or to or to get a mansion or
to hire sex operatives it's whatever
whatever they just need money that's
invisible
and it sounds Preposterous oh that could
never happen here yeah right you're like
you're a [__] child okay intelligence
ages agents agencies are bad they
recruit people that are bad you need
people that are morally flexible people
that can lie cheat steal kill and [__]
other people to get a job done there's
sex operatives there's all kinds of [__]
happening in there some of them are
underage
the recruitment might be from prisons it
might be from uh orphanages it and you
can say well that could never
that's been going on here for a long
time I actually saw things come out for
congress where they were taking women
out of or this is back in the 80s and
they didn't they kind of played no
contest they were taking women out of
the orphanages and torturing them to get
them to have multiple personality
disorder to turn them into damn sex
operators
and I think they were doing it in the
70s
but it kind of or at least the the girls
that were made the complaints were from
the 70s uh when that's but they were
making the complaint in the 80s but I
think they were talking about it
happening in the 70s
um
okay well one that we'll admit to or the
United States will admit to is that
North Korea has an extensive drug
manufacturing smuggling and sales
operation they use their their
intelligence agencies to do it
their intelligence agencies have a bunch
of
fishing boats is what they use
they they have spy equipment on them but
they use them to smuggle drugs and they
hand these drugs over to dealers at Sea
and then it
money's exchanged and then the product's
taken away but it's North Korea doing a
lot of it even even counterfeit money
you know they'll counterfeit U.S bills
and stuff so yeah this has happened this
happens this is a reality this is not
something just made up it's a part of
warfare
been going on for a long time
I mean I think [__] even during the
Napoleonic Wars what was it Napoleon had
all that
counterfeit Russian money printed up and
dumped it out [__] inside of Russia
or something to try to collapse their
copy I have to that's just off the top
of my head I'd have to go back it's been
going on forever
murder Hornet said my ex-navy seal
friend that later worked for the
government uh oga would you like
subcontractors for the CIA Etc told me
personally they smuggled drugs even when
he was in yeah like I said I don't um I
don't doubt it to be honest with you
um I don't know
like I I don't know how feasible it
would be to have like a CIA agent like
actually selling drugs they would get
like you said they would go a couple
layers back and like get other people to
do it which is what they essentially
ended up doing they have their own Air
Force called Evergreen
and they were shipping stuff around
go look for the Evergreen [__]
terminal inside any airport and you'll
eventually find it if it's a big airport
and that's them that's CIA
um that's their Air Force
but uh
yeah
um
at least what did he say oh what they do
is is they they need invisible money
so they can do things like buy weapons
and hire terrorists yeah for various
things that they don't want people to
know what you know about it and it can't
be traced back to them so drug money is
perfect
it's untraceable and it's cash and I'm
kind of feeling like this is probably
what was going on in this situation
because you know
that's essentially what they were doing
it was like getting some money in there
all right so before we start the show I
want to say that
every six months or so I will go back
through all the shows and read the
comments that have accrued
uh there'll be people in there trying to
get our attention and [__] hey you know
you haven't answered me we don't really
get notifications regularly anymore on
on YouTube well I do but sometimes I
don't have time to go through all of
them comments best way to get in con you
know the best way to get in contact with
us is through like well you can get in
contact with me through Instagram or
Facebook or uh what else what's to be
another way there's a way to to direct
message uh the show probably Instagram
huh
well I'm more likely to see the Facebook
comments Facebook and um or Facebook
messages
and maybe Instagram and also if you go
to the website like the 13 o'clock
WordPress the website where I um you
know post all the shows there is a
button there that you can write a
message and that comes directly to my
email and I'll for sure see that because
yeah you know check my email every day
it kind of sucks because we got super
fans in there you know trying to
communicate with us and yeah they'll
post a comment and I'll see like a new
comment on a video [__] eight months
old you know what I mean and had I
you know we really just don't we're not
reading those comments very rarely we'll
see them very late like I said I try to
keep up with them I can't keep up with
them the way I used to I feel like I
used to keep up with them like pretty
well but now there's like so many and
it's just kind of like I don't have
enough and I don't have a lot of time
like I used to
it's important contact us directly yeah
if not you guys could be a long time
before you get a reply
like I said I try I do try to like keep
up with stuff but sometimes I don't see
them or sometimes I don't have time
um to answer them like right away and
sometimes I'll be like oh maybe I'll
answer them this weekend and then like I
never get around we got super fans in
there we got [__] uh people
complaining super enemies uh people
wanting to know that I ain't gonna say
just [__] crazy [__] what do they
want to know uh a couple weeks ago
somebody wanted to know if you were
really female that was one I was like
what the [__] is this [__] talking
about uh uh just nice yeah he does
something is that a man you know [__]
that was I was like what the [__] go
back and go look at some videos they
have some cleavage you will definitely
see that that's a woman okay
um
what else did they [__] say uh uh one
dude was saying that I was corrupting
the youth
well yeah that's our goal
I'm like for [__] man good go out like
[__] soccer teams now I'm like
[__] Socrates they're gonna make me
drink hemlock for corrupting the youth
uh uh just it's crazy [__] they got
crazy people out there but other other
other listeners jumped on him and says
man what the [__] up he said we said
we were ageist too
okay
we're old too yeah I don't know it's
[__] funny sometimes that it's really
weird like sometimes people make
comments well I don't even know like
what it is that they're referring to or
what they got offended by you know what
I mean
I think well sometimes people just want
to be mad about something so it's just
like they want to comment on somebody or
it's like they don't understand like
Nuance they don't understand yeah humor
they don't understand like a lot of
things so you know what I mean so I
don't really pay that much another one
was a stupid cop I've been listening to
the show for a long time I used to love
it but now it's just boring because you
guys just get drunk and [__] and
[__] that's another one they're like
well that's what the show is kinda
well and honestly I feel like in the
last in the last few months
um you know since I've been working and
stuff I feel like we've been better
about yeah staying on topic yeah and not
getting this [__] trash I mean well
yeah because now I got to get up in the
morning so it's like I try not to get
like too [__] up yeah you're both
corrupting the youth and we're enjoying
it yeah it was corrupted to youth right
yeah funny and that's funny like
sometimes too like the comments are like
well are they trying to make a joke and
they just don't know how or are they
really serious I don't know I don't know
Jenny you a man lol yeah surprise uh
yeah not really but um that was the the
video when you first showed up with the
side of your head shaved
I figured that's probably like as soon
as you said that I was like that's
probably what it was yeah because no
girl is that no girl's gonna shaved
their head yeah right other than all the
ones that have so you know what I mean
[Laughter]
does that make Tom gay says murder
hornet
I could have sex with a man and [__]
still be straight
because if you actually do like blood
chemistry tests compared to me you just
look at the blood [__] testosterone
level compared to me most most men are
women anyway they're just like ugly
women
ugly women with a lot of hair on them I
don't usually stoop down that low
I can have sex with [__] dude I can have
sex with you and I'd still be straight
it's just you're a woman compared to me
man
it only gets dangerous when you try to
it's only becomes gay if I'm having sex
with like Jason Statham or [__] then
yeah that's gay that's good oh Tom just
went off on a little fantasy land yes
James Knapp said you've been a lot
better about staying on topic since the
new job I think it's because
um you know like I said one I can't
drink as much on the show because I have
to get up at five in the morning
um and two I you know I just got home
from work like an hour ago and it's like
I kind of wanna I don't want to rush the
show along but I want to make sure that
we get it done like at a reasonable hour
so I still have time to like relax roll
out before I have to go to bed you know
what I mean so there's that so I have
actually been trying to like kind of
keep it
keep it sort of on the thing but I know
that people do like the
the you know little diversions I mean I
like them too that's one of the things I
look forward to doing because I don't I
don't like to get too like wrapped up
and oh my God we can't talk about other
things like I don't want to get too anal
retentive about it but on the other hand
I don't want to be here for like five
hours either so there's that
so um anything else you'd like to any
more things you would like to imagine no
I'm gonna cut you those good you're
gonna cut me I'm gonna cut you loose go
ahead gee thanks it's like the horse you
know let it cut it loose so now I look
like a horse and a man yeah you're the
horse and a man no I'm saying when you
release you release the horse into the
[__] round pin or out in the pasture
and it does its own thing then do your
thing okay well thank you now uh yeah
just feel free to throw in any time
because like I said
this is a this is a massive massive
topic so I try to do like a lot of
research but I'm kind of a little bit
scattered at the moment
so let's do a little bit of background
in case as I said you weren't around
back then or you're not from the US or
something like that
so back in the late 1970s
in Nicaragua
you had a essentially like a military
dictatorship it was kind of like run by
a family and the head of it was uh
Anastasio samosa
now in 1978 1979 there was a you know
Revolution Uprising the Sandinista
Revolution
and uh they took out the you know
dictatorship or whatever
now the the dictatorship had been
actually backed by uh the U.S so they
were not happy about them getting taken
out and they didn't really have any
legal way to get them out of there
because of the way it happened so
they're like we got to think of
something else to do
so in the early 1980s uh Ronald Reagan
who was president then
he on the down low
um put aside about 20 million dollars uh
to set up a paramilitary force uh that
would be trained by the U.S of 500
nicaraguans they would be known as the
fdn we know them better as the contract
contrast yeah and some of my squad
leaders in the Army were ex-conscious
after all this [__] went down a lot
because they lost
basically they were some of them were
wanted for a lot of [__] they were uh
evacuated into the United States and uh
basically most of them inducted into the
United States Army they were good dudes
but
man they were
we had one guy I think his name was um
Sergeant Sandoval thinks what his name
was his wife was a was a contra
intelligence officer
who had basically tortured about 50
people and I think killed a lot of them
and uh
she was wanted she's like they had to
hide her and put her on a military base
the U.S military base for protection
yeah if I can remember when that [__]
when that [__] came out about him but no
we had contra's as Squad leaders in the
early 90s they were good man real good
dudes funny funny as [__] they're
ruthless though
yeah I guess so
we tried him over there at a place
called the school of Americas
that are coming out of yeah that was
that was like the first training hub for
him and then they from there they would
become Contra ncos and [__] they were
just a kind of a semi-professional
resistance fighter and we've always
talked about oh man there are [__]
funded terrorism and [__] that we've
been doing that for a long time we just
called them [__] Rebels or Freedom
Fighters or gorillas get hate us yeah
you can't call them terrorists yeah you
could call them you have to think of
like you gotta think of another name for
[__] a terrorist man yeah pretty much
and this [__] about putting
dictatorships in Central and South
America we were doing that going all the
way back to the [__] Banana Republic
Wars of the [__] early 1900s the
United States did a lot of damage to
Central that must be an interesting show
did you yeah like I saw a couple
documentaries about that a long time ago
and it was all because of these [__]
New York [__] investors up around
Wall Street wanting cheaper prices for
bananas
so they got all these banana farms and
stuff and Fruit Farms in Central America
and they want cheaper prices but their
their governments are want fair prices
so we'd overthrow that government and
put one that was friendly to us in there
dictatorship usually all right yeah we
can get cheaper prices
so yeah we did a lot of damage America
was you know all the propaganda side and
I served the US Army and everything and
the American people are great the
country's great its government has
[__] always been rotten always don't
[__] believe the hype it's been a
force of evil in the world for a long
time it's just that we recast it it's
something else we're helping no we're
not
no didn't help any of that any of those
places but look at the rock look at
Afghanistan we can help them
uh we did not
just made money doing it little projects
and [__]
Danny Rowling said the Beast of Jersey
AKA Edward paisnell serial rapist would
make a great True Crime show I actually
um wrote I put that in the poll a couple
times but it hasn't won so far but I do
actually want to do uh you know I do
actually want to do a show about that
but I do have that written down like on
my list you know I mean but we'd
overthrow those countries down in there
and it's been going a long time
uh so we could have a dictatorship there
to keep us safe from communism because
the Soviets were trying to overthrow
those governments too and put Communist
governments in there we couldn't have
that happen because they put missiles
over there and the missiles would be
closer so we're like oh well [__]
Central America we're gonna we're gonna
give them dictatorships
yeah pretty ruthless [__] ruthless
yeah I mean they don't really give a
rat's ass about the actual people who
have to live there no no it just didn't
want Russian missiles there it's all it
was yeah essentially and that was kind
of the case in uh Nicaragua as well yep
so so yeah so back in the 80s
um basically they're like all right so
we need to train this little army that
we got here that's backed by U.S money
and CIA and stuff like that uh so we
need to give give them obviously uh you
know supplies we need weapons and stuff
like that so we need a way to fund this
without anybody being the wiser you know
so uh essentially what they decided to
do hey I have a good idea let's get into
the drug trade
so um essentially what so what ended up
happening
was that
um and and this is you know where Gary
Webb would come in like later on in the
90s this is still in the 80s before he
like reported on it but essentially what
he was arguing happened was that the U.S
was
basically like they were funding not
really funding but they were allowing
um you know nicaraguans to flood
American streets uh you know starting in
Los Angeles but also in Miami too like
to a smaller extent with cheap crack
cocaine and all of the money they were
making obviously the dealers and stuff
like that would get their cut too but
then like all of the other money was
being funneled back to the contras
so that's basically what Webb was
arguing and that's pretty much like I
said I feel like they denied it denied
it denied it for like a really long time
but then later on they're like yeah we
did kind of know about that [__] you
know what I mean essentially but they
they didn't say that they did it but
they said we knew it was going on and
kind of more like turned a blind eye
kind of thing now interestingly
even though Gary Webb didn't write his
series until
1996. uh and it like I said it was
called Dark Alliance and he wrote a book
about it later too
there had actually been two guys from
the Associated Press and they reported
on this story way the [__] back in 1985.
uh their names were Robert Perry and
Brian Barger or Barger I'm not really
sure how you pronounce his last name so
I'm sorry about that
and they wrote a piece about it as well
in 1985.
and they found through their
investigations that uh Contra groups had
indeed engaged in cocaine trafficking uh
to finance their war against the
Nicaraguan the Sandinista government
and when they printed this I feel like
one of the reasons that that story in
1985 didn't get all as much traction as
it got like later on was because
um you know the the Reagan
Administration at the time uh they
started doing like little uh behind the
scenes kind of operations to basically
um kind of besmirched their reputations
like uh they discredited all the
reporting and it's like they you know
they had all these things going on that
said like oh that [__] wasn't true and
tried to like ruin their reputations and
stuff like that which was kind of like a
little bit of a
uh you know a little Bellwether of what
was going to happen to poor Gary Webb
like later on
um however uh in spite of all of the
kind of shady underhated dealings that
they were trying to do like to discredit
these two reporters the first ones that
broke the story back in 1985.
um some people in the government in the
American government were mad about it
and um you know so they wanted to kind
of get to the bottom of it so in um the
late 1980s there was actually a senate
subcommittee uh which was chaired by uh
John Kerry who was the senator at the
time and he him and his uh subcommittee
like looked into the charges
1989 they put out this massive report
like over a thousand pages
and basically and it was about mostly
about like the cocaine trafficking like
charges and stuff like that but it was
also like other covert operations that
have been going on in Latin America and
the Caribbean
and uh according to that report 1989
this came out uh the contras were
definitely linked to running guns and
drugs and that the US government knew
about it and was essentially allowing it
to happen and maybe trained them
allegedly and allegedly also was like
protecting drug dealers and things like
we told them to do that trained him how
to do it right right right come on and
uh the subcommittee report I have a
little quote from it right here on the
basis of this evidence it is clear that
individuals who provided support for the
contras were involved in drug
trafficking the supply network of the
contras was used by drug trafficking
organizations and elements of the
contras themselves knowingly received
financial and material assistance from
drug traffickers in each case one or
another agency of the US government had
information regarding the involvement
either while it was occurring or
immediately thereafter so that came out
of the report in 1989 and that was like
several years before Gary you know
printed his language picked up the story
and like printed his thing
so uh so yeah now
so this subcommittee report comes out
over a thousand Pages you'd think this
would be like a massive story not so
much uh didn't really get a lot of
attention from the papers
um and it kind of seems like I kind of
feel like maybe
um they were kind of like going maybe
the CIA was kind of going behind the
scenes to be like hey but you kind of
like not like not pay attention to that
or something like that because I do kind
of feel like a lot of you think that a
lot of newspapers will like pick up that
story but they really didn't like not it
there wasn't like a huge media outcry
about it until later on like when Gary
Webb did his thing
now the thing about it so
here's what happened with Gary Webb now
Gary Webb he actually started out
as a journalist I think he wrote for
like the Cleveland Plain Dealer and
stuff like that and he was actually uh
quite well respected he wrote a lot of
stories about
um you know a lot of what they would
call muck raking uh where he would just
uh you know he did one particular story
about a guy that was like you know with
mob ties and he did all that kind of
stuff like trying to you know bring down
the powerful type of thing and he
actually won um him and his team
like won a Pulitzer Prize a couple years
uh before all of this [__] happened
now as it occurred in the 90s he was
working for the San Jose Mercury News
was like a smaller newspaper like in
Northern California
and he had been doing a story about
um I was gonna say it was about what the
[__] was the story about oh it was about
asset forfeiture because prior to 1993 I
guess there had been a law in California
and elsewhere that if you were accused
of drug dealing no you took all your
[__] they took all your [__] like all
you needed was an accusation and he's
like that is some [__] right there
so he wrote like a big story about it
yeah yeah and he essentially said that
yeah so he wrote like a big story about
it three weeks after his story came out
they overturned that law and they said
now they can take your [__] but only
after you've been convicted which I was
like okay that's fine fair enough but
it's like at least there's a due process
right but it's like yeah just like
somebody's because you could hate your
neighbor and just be like hey my
neighbor's dealing crack and they're
like Shoop and they take all your [__]
because you can't prove that you didn't
buy that stuff with drug money you know
what I mean that was what they were so
it's like it's a stupid law I mean
obviously
but yeah so he had been working on a
story about that and it so happened that
he was approached
by this woman who was like the
girlfriend of like a drug dealer
and she was kind of the one that clued
him in to she's like you know
um all of this you know this whole big
crack epidemic which you know was kind
of a big story like in the 80s and 90s
with uh you know particularly South
Central Los Angeles like I said it kind
of started there and it kind of started
a little bit Miami and then I was
watching a thing with where Gary Webb
was talking where it kind of started in
two places and then kind of like met in
the middle like in the midwest but it
was just this massive massive thing
because it was you know cocaine had been
cut I feel like in the early to mid 80s
or maybe in the 70s as well it was kind
of like more expensive so it was kind of
more like a
maybe like a middle class and up kind of
drug it had money for cooking you had to
kind of have money for it um and then
crack came along
which you know was good for the dealers
because you could make a lot of it yeah
and it was you got like a really high
return yeah and it was highly addictive
so people would keep coming back like to
get more you know what I mean it was
just like 20 bucks you know for a hit
and then like they'd come back again and
get yeah they made a much bigger amount
of crap right so you could get like a
lot of your money back because I was
watching an interview with the guy I'm
gonna talk about in a minute who was
like a big drug dealer in La uh Freeway
Rick Ross
and um he said that no relation yeah
and uh well he's not white so you know I
mean you could still be related I
understand yeah but uh yeah I got black
cousins but they don't have my last name
that's true that's very common last name
yeah
but he was saying that when he first
started selling there's kind of like
some controvery of whether he was the
person that like sort of introduced
crack to South Central
um I don't know
how large his involvement was his
involvement was big for sure because he
was like one of the main big drug
dealers particularly of cocaine in in
that era
um but you know would it have happened
anyway without him who knows I don't
really know but he was saying that prior
to him starting to sell crack
um the main drug was PCP actually
they're like that was kind of the big
thing and marijuana because that was
illegal then but uh I was like really I
don't remember there being a big PCP
thing but yeah but he was saying yeah
that that was the main thing frying
their baby alive and putting yeah
that's right
going crazy and ripping your own arms
off trying to pick up the car uh yeah
you heard that [__] I've heard those
stories it was so strong he started
throwing cars until it ripped he ripped
his own arms off but I feel like I other
than like a few kind of you know random
urban legends like that yeah I kind of
feel like you didn't hear about PCP the
same way that you heard about crack or
cocaine or heroin or even PCP wasn't as
alluring not as many people did it that
yeah
but he was just saying that when he
first started selling cocaine everyone
kind of like made fun of him because
they're just like what nobody's doing
coke everybody's doing PCP now like why
don't you get with cool kids but um you
know I guess he he had the last laugh
because soon he was making like three
million dollars a day like selling
[__] crack on the streets of South
Central so you know what I mean
so yeah
free web got very interested in this
story that this woman had brought to him
because she's like you know she's like I
have actual proof that you know my
boyfriend the drug dealer
um had ties to the CIA who had ties to
the contras and we are you know we have
documentation that you know it's all
linked that that's where the money's
going it's going to fund the contras in
Nicaragua and Gary Webb is like well
that's very interesting um I'd be very
interested to see that uh that so she
brought him this big stack of paperwork
and he went to work on it I mean he
worked on this for
pretty much a year
um just doing all this research and [__]
like that now when this series came out
as I said at the time he was working for
the San Jose Mercury News which you know
is a smaller paper
and they published in 1996 uh his series
which is called Dark Alliance which
actually initially which is like three
articles like three long articles that
were published like over three days like
in August of 1996.
and what what it was was that it kind of
focused on
three guys in particular
one of these being the aforementioned uh
Freeway Rick Ross or Ricky Ross or
whatever who was a big one of the main
drug dealers in LA and like I said kind
of one of the people that helped to
introduce uh crack to uh South Central
which honestly really kind of devastated
um the black community which there was
like a whole generation it wasn't just
the fact that like people were on crack
but also this was during The Whole World
War on Drugs era when like the prison
sentences and [__] like that were
getting like really really bad
right yeah so so they were like Gary
Webb was even saying he's like you know
there's pretty practically a whole
generation of like young black men that
were just like just for possession and
stuff like that were put in prison for
30 years and [__] like that it was just
like [__] ridiculous so
you know and a lot of people in the
black community were like really really
mad that like all of this [__] stuff
had happened like all these drugs three
strikes you're out yeah yeah that's
right and the main proponent of that was
Joe Biden did you know that
he's big behind that
and now and they got rid of that though
good good thing it was really yeah they
got rid of that it was [__]
ridiculous
yeah like I said that just seems like a
down it's just ripe for abuse I kind of
feel like I remember that starting
during the Clinton Administration and me
being like that seems like a dumb idea
because that is just like I said it's
just ripe for abuse so you get arrested
for one little [__] thing and then
get arrested for another little [__]
thing and then you get arrested for a
third [__] thing and suddenly you're
in prison for life that's dumb the whole
War on Drugs was just a way of making
money out of make something out of
nothing
you could take a worthless white powder
and make it worth a [__] ton of money
and on on the back of that this you
could you could ramp it up as some kind
of a threat to society and make [__] ton
of contract money uh making police
forces and prisons
and then the same guys who's making
money off the prisons in the police
forces can double dip and get involved
in the drug trade they were doing that
bringing in the trucks on one end not
all of them but they were some guys were
making money on on that who were
politicians they were taking the [__]
too okay and then on the other end
they're making money selling contracts
to build prisons and [__] expand
police forces to make a damn police
state on the back of this people getting
high
let them get high even the DEA The Drug
Enforcement Administration was like this
is kind of draconian this is going to
cause a huge problems you really should
make all this stuff misdemeanors
and just try to control it and uh maybe
do some drug treatment programs and hand
some of it out for free you know but uh
the DEA at the time didn't want to crack
down on it at all
but hell no man the [__] house in the
Senate and everything they took and they
were going no we're going to make this
[__] we're gonna do this drug war we'll
make a [__] ton of money that's exactly
what they did
yes I said man America is a great place
I love the country love the people the
culture you got 50 different states that
joined up in his Union
and uh but Washington DC's man's a bunch
of [__] rats man
[__] criminals they don't give a [__]
about the people they just want to make
money
well yeah I mean anytime that much power
money you cannot centralize this much
power and have good people sitting on
those Thrones all right it's gonna be
[__] the worst kind of person you can
imagine that's what's that's what's
gonna make it there
uh just super [__] immoral [__]
power hungry and uh Liars that's what
that's what you're gonna have there
and the [__] they're all sociopaths
they're not even Psychopaths they're
sociopaths
well like I said you kind of have to be
to get up to a certain level like that
they'll just say anything
they don't believe anything they say
so um so yeah so this um series was
published
and the first article which I think came
out on the Sunday uh you know and then
the other one was Monday and Tuesday
the first sentence of it was for the
better part of a decade a San Francisco
Bay Area drug ring wait a minute I had
this written down here sold tons of
cocaine to the Crips and bloods street
gangs of Los Angeles and funneled
millions in drug profits to a Latin
American guerrilla Army run by the U.S
Central Intelligence Agency that was the
first sentence which you know also
um and this was would cause some
controversy later on the
artwork for the article I'm not sure
about the print version but the web
version and we'll get into that because
this was one of the first
um real big like expose muckraking
journalism things that went really big
on the internet because this was only
1996 remember so this was kind of like
one of the first things to kind of go
viral I guess maybe
um you know and like a small newspaper
kind of like taking over like the
national stage like that
so um but it had like artwork of the CIA
logo with like a silhouette of like a
dude smoking a crap crack pipe over it
so the CIA were a little bit upset by
that artwork I think they were more
upset by the artwork than anything else
but yeah
um so so the series was arguing
um or was kind of implying that the
um the cartels in Colombia
uh you know that there had been a
pipeline opened uh from there to you
know first to the black neighborhoods of
Los Angeles which kind of like caused
the whole crack explosion or at least
like kind of helped push it along like
to as bad as it got
now as I mentioned the uh the series
focused on mainly on three kind of key
players you had Freeway Rick Ross who
was like this big um La drug dealer then
you have this other guy who was a
Nicaraguan uh drug dealer named Oscar
Danny Lowe blandone and another
Nicaraguan dude named Norwin Meneses
Meneses I'm not really sure how you
pronounce his last name Menzies no it's
m-e-n-e-s-e-s Meneses
yeah now that I say it like that I'm
like yeah I think that's right
um so so we're kind of focusing on these
three guys
and what and also he got a little bit
into like later on how particularly
Blandon who was like this big deal like
a drug dealer like in Nicaragua how he
was essentially allowed to operate
pretty much with impunity
um
even though like probably he should have
been caught and prosecuted so that was
kind of why Gary Webb was arguing that
the CIA was kind of like just letting
him do his thing because
they you know they he never got like
arrested he never got prosecuted for
anything for like six seven years like
while he was doing all this stuff even
though you know he wasn't making a big
secret about it
now uh basically what ended up happening
was that uh Blandon he kind of like went
into his background and he started
smuggling because he was a contrast
supporter and he actually started
smuggling cocaine to give them money
that's what he started doing
and then you also had uh manesses who
was also a contra supporter and also a
Smuggler and he was the one that taught
Blandon how to smuggle and gave him the
coke
that they cooked into crack
now
Freeway Rick Ross who like I said
previously had been kind of selling uh
you know he'd been selling PCP and weed
and stuff then he started selling
cocaine but then like when this whole
crack thing uh started out and he kind
of saw a market for that
um he started buying crack from blandone
and because he essentially had the only
hook up for that and because he was such
a big drug dealer he pretty much had the
LA market like under lock as far as
crack was concerned
um so you either bought from Freeway
Rick Ross to sell your crack in LA or
you didn't get any you know what I mean
because he was kind of the only dude
that had the hookup
so those were the first two articles and
then the third one was kind of more
about
uh the repercussions like what was
happening in particularly in South
Central Los Angeles like among the black
community like what the cultural effects
of like the crack epidemic were uh so
there was that whole thing too and then
there also was kind of some stuff about
uh the differences between how uh how
Blandon was treated and how Rick Ross
was treated like after their arrest he
was kind of like trying to do like a
racial profiling thing which he actually
wrote some articles about that later on
about like um racial profiling and like
traffic stops and stuff like after he
got uh after he was
booted off the paper and was writing
about like other things
so he writes this three
series thing and they and they actually
wrote more articles about it like you
know over the next three months like
kind of expanding on it a little bit and
as I mentioned
um this was the first I mean stuff had
been published on the internet before
like I said this was 1996 was like the
early days of the internet but this was
kind of the first one that was like a
big deal and everybody was like really
impressed because not only did it have
all the articles there like on you know
and everyone around the world could read
them but it also had like all these
links to interviews that he had done
like with all the players and like all
the you know the backup like the records
that he had like to back up his
assertions and things like that so
anybody in the world could like go in
there and look at it so it was like a
big
this was like a big thing and as I said
the the artwork that was on the uh the
website with the CIA logo with the guy
with crack pipe um yeah the CI were
particularly mad about that they did end
up taking it down later on because it
was like too controversial and they said
that makes it look like we're selling
the crack and they're like well you know
but uh so there was that
now interestingly so the [__] comes out
and immediately there is a massive
to kind of I mean people were just like
freaking out and were like mind blown or
like you know I feel like now of days it
would come out and everybody would be
like yawn but but I guess like in the
90s it was a big [__] deal like
everybody was like freaking out about it
now what ended up happening though
interestingly is that you would think
that
um
that after a story of this magnitude
went you know the 1996 equivalent of
viral I guess
you would think that like other major
newspapers would want to pick it up uh
pick up the story like expand upon it do
their own investigations and like get in
on the [__] which
they kind of did but not really in a way
that you'd expect basically what they
did was they came in and they started
trying to like poke holes in the story
like like he had overstated it you know
what I mean so they were kind of trying
to downplay it a little bit what one of
our uh best supporters in front of the
show Louis Hernandez has just showed up
well hey there what's up Louie
Camp guy said it sounds like a James
Bond movie yeah well Ian Fleming knew
exactly what he was talking about
yeah this kind of [__] happens all the
time it's not like he wasn't like making
that [__] yeah Anthony just didn't pull
that out of his ass he was part of OSS
which is a
kind of like a precursor to the CIA
during World War II and uh cousin to um
the dude who played Dracula what's his
name um Christopher Lee Christopher Lee
that's right cousin to Christopher Lee
isn't that crazy yeah it's a small world
yeah yeah what's up Louie what's going
on
but not for all the movies man I think
we got it we got all his movies reviewed
I think I think we did yeah yeah if you
forgot one man drop it in the comment
section because you sent us so many over
the years
I think I got all of them but there was
a time during the move when when some
videos came I know and
I think we lost the order whether or not
we actually reviewed them and I think we
got them all these yeah sometimes like I
said I try to keep track of [__] but
yeah
I kind of wish I had a secretarium but I
can't afford to hire one I'm gonna get
you a girlfriend that would keep track
of [__] for me
I'm gonna get you a girlfriend but the
thing about
if I had that
I wouldn't trust them to do it right
yeah because you know what I mean I'm
kind of a control freak a little bit not
I don't know if I'd call myself a
control freak but I'm always just like
well I want things done a particular way
and I don't have time to like explain to
people how to do it so I'm just I'm just
like [__] it I'll just do it
it's easier than having to explain to
somebody else how to do it so yeah
um so the San Jose Mercury News The
Breakfast Club did he send us a
breakfast club oh yeah yeah that's right
okay we'll do breakfast club wait we
didn't review that I guess we didn't
oh [__] man I guess we didn't oh man we
need to do that I thought we did I
thought we did too I have to look back
and look I mean maybe we saw it and then
never reviewed and then forgot it but I
forgot to like forgot to do the review
yeah it may have happened and I love
that movie to be honest I probably don't
even have to watch it again because I've
seen it so many times like it's like
I've almost like memorized it
James said hire me as a higher Tom as
the secretary you have no idea what the
[__] you're talking about man I could he
wouldn't be good
no offense I'm just saying no you would
not be you're not good with that kind of
thing no he's not a good organizational
no person I'm the organization you can't
really organize data that real real well
not really good at that
and I can't organize equipment physical
stuff I can't up to a point but then
after a while even I still like stuff
start slipping through the cracks
because I told him I was like you don't
understand like inside my brain yeah
it's like having a hundred like tabs
open on Google at one time like all the
time it's always like that
um
uh Danny Rowling said Jenny needs to
review the film valley girl uh yeah I
actually had been wanting to do valley
girl for a really long time Tom's never
seen it uh Nicholas Cage was in it when
he was really young and um it's got a
good soundtrack too it's got Modern
English and Psychedelic Furs and how
long ago
um what an hour okay hour okay yeah
super chats are active people and if
you're listening to this recorded we
also have uh super thanks you can give
us that and uh do we want to do
commercials now or do you want to do
them later
uh I guess we could do them now I'm just
gonna do a commercial now because we
might be almost halfway through it
anyway yeah we probably are okay all
right so we're gonna do some commercials
and then we'll be back in a minute
[Music]
died
in the despairing posture
again
[Music]
death
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
all right we're back look at it's just
the top of time I should
I was gonna wait but then I was like why
haven't you got time for them waiting on
me
well yeah yeah so uh we got [__] to do
we always have [__] to do
but yeah so uh let's see where was I
okay so the the Articles get published
and like I said the the main three
where over three days like in August of
1996 and then like over the next three
months like they kept uh publishing like
follow-ups and stuff like that
um
now and other papers didn't really uh
they weren't real quick to pick up on
the story
however uh the black community in uh Los
Angeles were pissed at the allegations
the implied allegations because like I
said Gary Webb when I saw an interview
with him
um or you know his talk that he gave out
Berkeley he basically stated out right
you know I don't think that the CIA
actually like directly like selling
drugs into you know South Central in
order to purposely like destabilize the
black community or something like that
like I said I can see why they might
believe that but he's like I don't
really believe that's what's going on
that was just like a bat like a sad side
effect of like what they were trying to
do
which is just like making money and they
found like a market and that's just what
happened and the rest of it was just
like sad Fallout but um but so yeah so
the black community was like
particularly mad and they kind of like
took the story and ran with it and they
had like all kind of like [__] town
meetings where they were like shouting
at the Senators and everything like that
now uh two California Senators
Barbara Boxer and uh Dianne Feinstein uh
they kind of like we need to get to the
[__] bottom of this so they actually
like went to the CI then CIA director
his name is John Deutsch and uh Janet
Reno who was then the attorney general
and said uh you guys need to investigate
this [__] because uh you know this this
is not a good look uh Maxine Waters who
is also the representative for the 35th
District in California of which uh you
know South Central Los Angeles is a part
um she actually became one of Gary
Webb's um you know biggest supporters
because she was just like uh completely
outraged by the um articles and the fact
that the CIA would be doing that kind of
[__] and uh you know so there and
there's actually she was um at one of
the hearings there's I think it's on
YouTube somewhere it's like two and a
half hours long and I watched like
little parts of it but yeah she's like
super pissed
so um so yeah so there were all these
calls for investigation into it so about
a month after the series first was
published uh there were three Federal
investigations that were beginning to be
undertaken now uh interestingly the
investigation into the allegations
against the CIA that they knew what was
going on uh was conducted by Guess Who
the CIA itself yeah the CIA Inspector
General are we still invested who at the
time we didn't do it the other day uh
was named Frederick hits yeah
uh they were also doing an investigation
into law enforcement just the fact that
law enforcement was just kind of like
letting stuff slide like not
investigating like all of these key
players uh so they went into that like
the justice department
um Inspector General uh investigated
that and then there was another
investigation into the CIA by the house
intelligence committee so three
investigation investigations uh and also
because Gary Webb kept writing like
follow-up articles uh they also did a
fourth investigation into the [__] so
like they so people did take notice you
know what I mean it's not like nothing
happened
now um the thing about it one of the
things that they were because remember I
said that they were talking about
law enforcement and how like a lot of
them kind of turned a blind eye to [__]
and they brought up like a bunch of
examples where particular drug dealers
were like doing [__] like out in the
open and like law enforcement were like
la la I don't see anything kind of thing
you know what I mean
um one of the examples that they gave
was like this raid that had happened in
1986 on uh Blandon who was the big
Nicaraguan guy
um the LA Sheriff's Department which
seemed to be the only law enforcement uh
you know agency that gave a [__] about
any of these allegations or were
actually trying to do something about it
but they actually
um did a raid on this dude's uh I don't
know if it's his house or his Justice
operation in general and allegedly and
I'm saying allegedly so don't sue me
allegedly they had they found evidence
that tide land on directly to the CIA
but this um
but this evidence was uh you know kind
of covered up you know what I mean
so uh so yeah
and uh also the so the LA Sheriff's
Department started looking into [__] on
their own like I said they seem to be
like the only major law enforcement
agency that was like yeah we need to do
something about this everyone else was
just like yeah we're gonna pretend it's
not happening
now
as I said interestingly after these
claims
a lot of the other major newspapers in
the country
didn't pick up the story and expand upon
it as you would think maybe
um they said well we're gonna do our own
investigation into it but a lot of them
got kind of like hostile against Gary
Webb in particular and we're saying that
the article was
overstated or he had made a bunch of
allegations that he couldn't
substantiate that you know what I mean
that weren't backed up
now while it is true that some of and I
am going to say like I have read
portions of it I will say that he did
use some kind of like overheated
language a little bit like they do you
know what I mean to get people to read
it
and he did make some implications that
maybe if you wanted to read it a certain
way like maybe he's saying a particular
thing so because I think that a lot of
people took it that he was saying that
the CIA was like directly like selling
drugs into like you know bringing drugs
into LA and I don't think he ever said
that directly now you could read it in a
way that it did sound like he was
implying that and I think people were
mad that he didn't have any like direct
evidence of it you know what I mean so I
think that they thought that he was like
overstating things which okay fair
enough maybe he was
but all these other papers really
[__] piled on him I think that maybe
this is weird but like to a smaller
extent you have to think this is like
the 1990s still
and this explosive expose was published
in not a dinky paper but like you know
not a major newspaper it was San Jose
Mercury News you know what I mean like
in Northern California
and I think that a lot of the major
newspapers like particularly the LA
times because they really like raked him
over the coals I think they were mad
that he had scooped them
so they were gonna like you know shoot
holes in his credibility because I think
they were upset that he was getting all
the attention I think that was maybe one
of the things that was going on because
there is kind of like [__] like
jealousy and stuff like that in
newspaper in journalism you know what I
mean so I worked for a newspaper I did
yeah yeah she knows about the answer she
we're not talking about their asses
we've actually had worked in some of
these fields that we talk about
yeah I'm not saying that that was the
entire thing I just think that that
might have been a factor particularly
with the LA times because the LA Times
is like we're like the major California
newspaper and it's like here's this
dinky ass Northern California and they
have this big thing and I think they
were mad too because it was like one of
the first big web uh you know articles
and everybody was talking about it and
stuff like that I think they were upset
that they hadn't done yeah [__] you
know that's what I mean so I think there
was a little bit of [__] I don't think
that's the only thing that was going on
but I think that that was for sure a
factor they probably got orders to
[__] try to [__] put the kibosh on
that I kind of feel like maybe because
the CIA has its figures in the media
bigger than [__] and also in Hollywood
that all happened during World War II
when they were still the OSS when the
CIA formed after World War II one of
their [__] biggest arms of operation
was
Hollywood Hollywood and [__]
television
because uh that's your propaganda arm
the American movies are propaganda
people don't realize it prod it's not
just corporations involved in that [__]
doing product placement there's uh
intelligence agencies and political
groups in there putting [__] messages
in there
because the entire world sees those
movies or they used to and they don't
watch that [__] now but [__] back in
the day
um in the uh
uh in in the in the 60s 70s 80s you know
what I mean [__] a good American
movie was seen all around the [__]
globe so you can show off how much
better you were than the Soviet Empire
there's all kinds of stuff that they
were doing
well there was a thing that came out
like many years later like because I
don't know if you guys know um but there
was a movie that came out in 2014 called
Kill the Messenger which was about Gary
Webb it was basically like and I've
heard it's really good I haven't seen it
um I was actually gonna watch it before
the show but I didn't have time you had
to like rent it it was 3.99 and I was
gonna watch it like on my lunch hour and
I was like [__] I don't have time to
like watch it because I was watching
some other documentaries so I didn't
have time to watch it but I've heard
it's good Jeremy Renner is in it he
plays uh Gary Webb and uh it's based on
like a biography of Gary Webb that came
out like a couple years after he died
but um but yeah it came out like later
on that the CIA were actually kind of
like you know certain factions within
the CIA were kind of scrambling when
Gary Webb's series came out because they
said whether they're like you know
whether the allegations are true or not
they're like this is a really bad public
relations disaster essentially so we
have to
mitigate this somehow so I think maybe
they did kind of go to
certain like you know larger newspapers
and stuff like that kind of suggests to
them it's like you know he said all this
stuff he just like pulled this out of
his ass he can't back up these claims so
you know maybe he encouraged like maybe
they encouraged like some of the other
newspapers to like write something that
was like super critical of him and
indeed a lot of them did
uh the first article that came out
criticizing the dark Alliance series uh
actually showed up in October in the
Washington Post
and uh two reporters wrote that and they
basically said that um you know while
some of the a few of the allegations
might have been true they're like um
that the evidence that he put forth in
the article didn't uh support the claims
that he was making and they also said
that well the whole rise of crack could
not be attributed to just one person or
one thing it was kind of like happened
in a lot of different places at once so
he was simplifying it
and you know various other things like
about his relationship with Freeway Rick
Ross like in the whole thing with the
attorney because I kind of feel like
Freeway Rick Ross at the time like the
drug dealer he was
um trying to
he was on trial so he was kind of trying
to maybe lessen his
culpability a little bit and I think
they kind of looked into claims so like
his attorney was saying it's like oh the
CIA made me do it kind of thing you know
what I mean very simple sort of thing
um Tom and Jenny you guys should look
into the murder of DEA agent Enrique
Kiki Camarena in 1985 in Mexico by The
Guadalajara cartel who kidnapped him and
killed him allegedly with the CIA oh
that's another good yeah okay let me
write that down because yeah I had like
so many things written out over here
okay so we're gonna look up Enrique
Camarena
I will put that in the next poll
probably well yeah I can put it in this
poll because this poll hasn't gone up
for this weekend so I can put it in
there and see how that I've seen Mexican
cartel members videos of them just out
in the street picking things up you know
they got the vehicles all around them
they're armed
it's a [__] cartel member definitely
a cartel member look at him Caucasian
the way he's carried himself and it's
just his skill set what he's doing with
his hands how he handles the weapon I'm
going that's US Army infantry X Infantry
so it's it just
you know and I had I had a friend who's
doing time
we were in the Army together and he ran
a Central and South American death squad
basically okay
and uh his name is vanvakius Timothy MC
vanvakius you can look it up he's doing
time right now but he'll be back out
he uh killed a
he's either attempted to kill a DEA
agent or or killed the DEA agent I don't
know if he was a dirty DEA agent or what
or but his clientele were
cartels and
people in the Central American
governments many of them
they were going to make a movie about
him
just Google Timothy vanvakius and I can
show you pictures of me and him together
in my yearbook in Korea
good buddy Marty stayed in this service
for a long time got out of the high
ranking and NCO
and was doing that running death squads
for many countries many governments
and uh
it had to be CIA
if you get compromised you go to jail
all right they don't save you because if
they save you
then that's okay then they know but no
he's CIA
so they were trying one of the things oh
for reason why I mentioned him is
because vanvakis and his men they were
International mercenaries some of them
were European they had Russians they had
Americans one of their big gigs was to
give military training to like multiple
cartels down there
that the CIA probably from behind the
scenes helped control
but being a trainer is big business
training cartel members
okay go ahead
so the next thing that came out uh one
reporter named Tim golden wrote two
articles for the New York Times
in which
um he basically said the same thing that
like the evidence in the uh series
didn't back up like the assertions uh
brought up the stuff with Freeway Rick
Ross and his attorney and uh basically
said that he didn't think like according
to his sources he didn't think like the
drug dealers that Gary Webb talked about
in his article were as important as he
had made them seem
uh you know just in terms of how much
money they actually gave to the contras
or how involved they were in introducing
crack or whatever they were basically
saying again that like all of the
allegations were overstated
now the LA Times went overboard and like
I said I think that there was maybe a
little bit of professional jealousy here
because they were mad that they had been
scooped on such a big story because they
got 17 reporters a team of 17 reporters
to basically I don't know if they
basically said hey discredit him but
they're like we need to like go over
this story with a fine-tooth comb and
like find some [__] that's like not
legit you know what I mean
so they did a whole series 17 [__]
reporters and one of the reporters later
on said they actually called it the get
Gary Webb team that's what they called
it which is crazy so there was four
reporters that wrote the three articles
that eventually ended up
coming out and uh essentially they were
making the same argument that it's like
oh the crack epidemic is a lot more
um complicated than he's making it seem
like it came from like a lot of
different sources at once not just kind
of one place as he was implying
um you know and sort of that just that
kind of thing
and uh again claimed that they didn't
give that these particular that blend on
and um minute how did I say it before um
yeah or something like that I just I
said it right and then like now I can't
remember how to say it right yes
that's what I was thinking
uh Louis said yeah the LA Times was
jealous because Webb got his story first
yeah I kind of feel like that played a
part for sure they're [__] yeah well
it's just like any other professional I
mean you want to be the one that gets
the big I mean you know you want the
accolades you want the Pulitzer you want
the whatever if somebody else like
Scoops you on the show you're gonna be
mad those all those old news agencies
today live in a Perpetual state of of
custom they're cucked out constantly
because in the modern era everybody got
a cell phone so they're all Breaking
people in the streets are breaking all
the news they don't do shitty now well
and I kind of feel like this particular
story when dark Alliance came out
because like I said it was kind of the
first one that went major like on the
internet because you know it was pretty
internet was in pretty early days back
then and I think that they were maybe
they were mad about that too that now
like a small newspaper could break this
huge story that was like getting like
Federal investigations and [__] like
that and it bypassed like the larger
newspapers so I think they were a little
bit upset well if you look at the larger
news newspapers even today and it was
like this back then they're all about
numbers making money okay uh they didn't
they didn't do a whole lot of
investigative journalism because that
takes too long it's not you got to
invest a lot of time and a lot of money
and then you're gonna you know six
months later a year later then you got
one story to put in your paper
and a lot of times the story isn't
sensational
so if you if you look at what they're
doing now is they mostly just do stories
on the stories that they read in other
newspapers it's like a chain well like I
said it's easier you don't have to well
I mean the thing about the San Jose
Mercury News even though I will say that
in the end they did kind of end up like
[__] like selling Gary Webb out a
little bit but for a while they actually
encouraged him I mean they they poached
him from another paper because he was a
really good he won a Pulitzer Prize like
I said I think he won it for I think it
was the Cleveland Plain Dealer if I'm
not mistaken but they you know offered
him a job to come out to California and
work there because they were looking for
an investigative journalist and on this
particular story even after the [__]
started to hit the fan and everyone
started to criticize the story and
saying it was and shooting at full holes
they did allow him to do further they
even they flew him to Nicaragua like a
couple of times and like let him do like
follow-up stories and [__] like that but
in the end like he said investigative
journalism is an expensive proposition
like for a newspaper you have to pay for
your reporters to go places and yeah and
they could be gone for months and like I
said you know that then there's no
guarantee that the story is going to be
any good or anyone's going to read it or
anything like that so it's much easier
to just kind of like scour the web and
it's like rewrite some [__] yeah that's
what they're doing that somebody you
know that's that doesn't take any yeah
and now that they have ai like they have
article Spinners that'll kind of that
just do it for you yeah and you just
kind of tweak it a little bit yeah
foreign critics of the US news media
have noticed that now it's just an
incestuous relationship against like
between like four or five major U.S new
news uh papers you know like Washington
Post New York Times all that crap LA
Times and all they do is mirror each
other you know I mean they're just
trying to sell material they they're not
serious anymore I mean they're still
investigative journalism going on but
it's generally smaller yeah it's
generally smaller it's on the internet
more independent yeah independent
internet type stuff that actually care
about the [__] that like want to get the
information newsprint television news
media I can't believe that they still
got old people watching [__]
television man you watch television
it'll depress the [__] out of you you're
transported back to [__] 1994 and
[__] but I can't believe people still
consume that media because it's just so
backwards you know
um backwards and boring
the internet's so much better man I'm so
glad for for free and open internet
uh the information is better and it
comes faster and it all comes with
videos because people are just [__]
witnessing it firsthand with cell phones
and [__] I mean it's harder to keep up
with stuff now for sure because there's
so much more of it but I would rather it
be like that well yeah you know it's the
way it always was Independent News it
was always like that before it's just
you didn't know about it you didn't know
about all the [__] going on and then um
well what you do is you go uh YouTube's
a good source rumble's pretty good
you're gonna find people that curate
that go through all this [__] you know
every or and we'll uh kind of put a
little report out you know of any
subject you want you know they're
watching their own particular subject so
specialized news
you know like just talking about Disney
they got dudes that have a channel just
talking about the news that's leaking
inside the Disney Corporation between
Kathleen Kennedy and Bob you know and
all these you know they want to know
what the Mandalorian is going to be like
and why are they [__] guess what
people they're gonna Disney's gonna sell
Star Wars
that's the newest leak
Disney says that Star Wars is [__] up
they can't fix it they're gonna sell it
they're going to keep Marvel though I
believe it the sources are very good
we'll see if that happens
well Marvel is like [__] printing
money man yeah they're gonna keep Marvel
because they can fix Marvel it's had
some problems but they don't think they
can fix Star Wars they're gonna sell it
but yeah so the LA times as I said
printed you know they did their own
thing 17 [__] reporters researching
this [__] which like I said even some of
the reporters later like that seems a
little like Overkill you know what I'm
saying at least one of the reporters
that worked on the series that was
trying to essentially like discredit
Gary Webb's story or at least say that
it was exaggerated uh his name was
Jessie Katz he actually came out later
on uh and sort of apologized he felt
kind of bad about it like in 2013 he
came out
he said uh and this is a quote from him
he said as an LA Times Reporter we saw
this series in the San Jose Mercury News
and kind of wondered how legit it was
and kind of put it under a microscope
and we did it in a way that most of us
who were involved in in it I think would
look back on that and say it was
Overkill we had this huge team of people
in the LA Times yeah this is a massive
paper back then and kind of piled on to
one lone muckraker up in Northern
California
and he also said we didn't really do
anything to advance his work or
illuminate much to the story and it was
really kind of a tawdry exercise and it
ruined that reporter's career because I
kind of feel like the story
so he had put out this story
and I feel like the responsible thing to
have done yes like investigate the
claims I mean they're explosive claims
as I said so yes you should investigate
that because it's entirely possible that
some of them are not true or they're
exaggerated or something like that so
that's a completely legitimate exercise
but I do kind of feel like as that went
on and as more papers started to do that
I mean and some papers did defend him
like the guy from The Baltimore Sun and
everything like that did come out and
say it looks like good investigative
journalism to me yeah maybe he used like
some little overheated language or
something but everybody does that it's
not that big a deal but I kind of feel
like because that happened to him I kind
of feel like it became the story Gary
Webb wrote this thing that was
exaggerated and nobody really got
interested in the actual story anymore
or like actually getting to the bottom
of the actual story because it all kind
of came about became about the guy and
like the claims that he was making
instead of people actually investigating
the actual claims are trying to like
expand upon the claims you know what I'm
saying so if there was somebody behind
that like if somebody like that in the
CIA like you know PR office or whatever
if they were behind that they did a good
job because they very successfully like
got the focus away from the allegations
that the CIA had you know done all this
wrongdoing and actually got the focus
back on Gary Webb like the reporter that
you know broke the story so you know
they they did a good job there have to
say
I will say Okay so the San Jose Mercury
News I mean they must have known that
the story was going to be controversial
for sure
but I think they were surprised at the
reaction of the rest of the media or not
all of the rest of the media but you
know the larger newspapers I think they
were surprised by it
now at that time the executive editor of
the Mercury News
was named Jerome sepos
um and he actually wrote To The
Washington Post and he stuck up for Gary
Webb like saying you know he defended it
The Washington Post however would not
print his defense would not print his
letter
um and also just to be on the safe side
he actually got another reporter at the
San Jose Mercury News the same newspaper
to kind of like write a
a critique of Gary Webb's series just so
so it would look like it was more
balanced I guess
um and also like I said they took down
the the artwork that the CIA had cried
about like on the on the website I don't
think it was in the print article but it
was for sure on the website which more
people saw because that was like a
million hits a day which back then was
like a huge amount
so they printed uh this article by you
know another guy at the same paper
critiquing it so it would look more
balanced and [__] like that
um you know
and so then when the LA Times thing came
out
um the you know the editor he again like
wrote to the LA Times Like defending the
original series and you know did
interviews like all over the place where
he's like you know Gary Webbie's a you
know he's a good investigative
journalist if he said this he had all
this stuff like to back up his
everything
um but you know what I mean
but the thing about it was that he got
so much blowback that he's like okay
well I guess now we have to kind of like
acknowledge that this is a really
controversial thing and like maybe we
should go back over it because maybe
Gary Webb did make some mistakes maybe
he did over exaggerate some claims maybe
he doesn't have some stuff to like back
up as everything
so um he basically came out and he's
like I still defend the series I still
think it was well researched but we are
gonna like look into it to make sure
that he wasn't making any allegations
that he can't back up
so um so yeah
and so it was like this big back and
forth for like a really long time
and as I said there were some newspapers
that defended uh Gary Webb like I said
particularly The Baltimore Sun and I
should say too that the Society of
professional journalists actually gave
Gary Webb the journalist of the Year
award uh that year
without too much controversy I think one
guy didn't want to do it but they were
like yeah shut up and they gave it to
him anyway
now so basically after that like the the
newspaper that had originally published
Gary Webb series they did uh several
months
um internal review like a critique of
the story
and uh by a couple different people that
worked at the paper
and their conclusion was that they
basically found
um some problems with some parts of the
story
uh and as I mentioned earlier they did
actually give Gary Webb money to go back
to Nicaragua to get more stuff like get
more evidence to like back up his story
like you know
um so Gary Webb was there for a while he
actually wrote four more articles like
while he was in Nicaragua when he came
back and filed them
but uh the editors uh they eventually
decided not to print them because they
didn't think that they um substantiated
his claims to any great degree like any
more than the original one had so he did
all that for nothing so like I said they
did send him to Nicaragua paying this
then Nicaragua but they didn't print the
stuff that he wrote
and uh they also did not print the other
guy's uh critique of the [__] either
but they did let Gary Webb keep working
on the story they sent him back to
Nicaragua again uh you know a couple
months later and uh so that whole thing
was done and then they published another
uh column in 1997 in May of 1997.
and
didn't happen but then the editor kind
of came out and said well we kind of
think the original series and all the
subsequent stuff there were all these
areas where maybe it could have been
better
um they were like there was some
conflicting evidence
um that was not presented in the article
that maybe would have contradicted some
of the article's assertions they're like
that was one thing
um they said that the amount of money
involved and how much the drug dealers
were contributing to the contras was
presented as a fact and not as an
estimate that was also another thing
that they uh said was not right
um they also said that the article the
original art series of Articles
oversimplified the um the start the
origin of the crack epidemic making it
seem as though you know this whole thing
that you know Rick Ross and all them
like in Bland on they were the ones that
opened up the pipeline essentially when
they were like well it kind of happened
in a bunch of places at once
and um also they said that there was
some language in there that was quote
unquote imprecise that would give people
Impressions that maybe uh were not
able to be substantiated
um you know and Gary Webb came out and
just said you know [__] you guys uh you
know he stood by his [__] and uh you
know but the editor was kind of like
um he did actually the editor did take
responsibility he's like I'm the one
that printed the [__] so you know that's
kind of my thing
now Gary Webb was mad as hell about this
um as as you might imagine
and uh he basically accused his editors
and everything like that of uh quote
unquote selling him out he thought they
sold him out
and um
you know but the the other editors of
the paper were like yeah but you know
there were all there was all this other
evidence that contradicted what you were
saying and you didn't tell us about bad
and it's just like all this other kind
of stuff because I read like some other
people like some other people that have
worked with Gary Webb and most of them
were kind of like yeah he was like a
[__] great investigative journalist
you know he was amazing
um but a couple people did say well he
had a tendency to like over exaggerate
claims or something like I don't know if
that's true or not but I'm just saying
that a couple people did say that
so what they did like just to kind of
settle this whole brouhaha
they didn't fire him from the San Jose
Mercury News but basically what they
said they're like well you can't work in
the Sacramento Bureau anymore which is
where he lived in Sacramento so that's
the place where he was working
they're like you can either move to the
main offices in San Jose uh and have
like an editor pretty much like barking
down your snorkel all the time
or you can go to is it Cupertino
you're from California I've never heard
of that place
um or you can go there and just do kind
of like spot reporting like whatever
story comes up and you cover it
both of these these jobs it should be
noted were very long commutes from where
he lived he lived in Sacramento I think
that where he ended up going I think he
said it was 140 miles like one way and I
was like holy [__] talk about and I talk
about [__] about my commute which is 54
miles it takes about an hour but uh but
yeah
so he was not happy about either of
these decisions but he did take the one
in uh Cupertino
but he only worked there for a little
while he's like the commute was super
long like I said I think it was 140
miles
um and they were just giving him a bunch
of [__] stories to cover So
eventually he [__] quit
now uh so yeah so after that the federal
investigation results kind of came out
not surprisingly a lot of the ones that
kind of came out were basically all they
found was that yeah there were tentative
links between it it essentially it
boiled down to the CIA they think that
certain elements of the CI now some of
the investigations like the CIA invested
like nobody knew anything we don't we
don't know anything
but some of the other investigations
came out and said well they do think
that the CIA was at least turning a
blind eye or
protecting certain people like they for
sure knew what was going on like with
the drug dealers vis-a-vis you know and
they were actively like not allowing
people to be persecuted like prosecuted
because they wanted the [__] to continue
well they knew where the money was
coming from right right
so that was kind of like the thing that
they came out with even though like I
said the CIA report was kind of like
yeah here's the thing this is not
unusual for the for intelligence
agencies
no it's not unusual they'll deal with
prostitution drugs they'll deal with
anything human trafficking
yeah if it's money and power or a way to
get a hold of something that they want
they'll do it
there's no oversight
it's run like a their own little fiefdom
yeah
but uh but yeah so but like I said it
kind of felt like
a lot of the reports that came out even
though they did
it did kind of vindicate a few of his
claims namely that CI did kind of know
what was going on
um but a lot of the implications that he
was making in the series you know that
the CIA actively knew what was happening
and like they were helping funnel like
millions of dollars like back to the
contras and all this other kind of stuff
most of the federal investigation said
yeah we didn't find any evidence of that
I don't know if that's true probably not
that they didn't find any evidence of it
they're like yeah we found evidence but
we threw it away or ate it or something
now so Gary Webb you know he was working
at this other you know in Cupertino or
whatever
and uh he decided that he was going to
take the dark Alliance series the
article series and turn it into a book
and so he did that and so he expanded
the Articles out he got more evidence
and he also kind of incorporated into
the book
um all of the criticisms that he had
received and kind of like tried to
address those and also just the whole
like [__] [__] show surrounding it
like the controversy and the controversy
and like what had happened to him and
stuff like that so the book came out in
and it's called Dark Alliance the CIA
the contras and the crack cocaine
explosion like I said if you look on
YouTube
um I had to dig around a little bit to
find it but there is a footage of him
talking at Berkeley like right after
this book came out like it's about an
hour long uh and he's kind of like
talking and it's actually like pretty
interesting and then they published a
revised version the following year uh
that had him talking about because
that's when all the federal
investigation reports came out and so he
was like responding to that
um and it the book came out and it won
like a bunch of awards so you know what
I mean
now what ended up happening after that
is that
um not surprisingly Gary Webb got a
little bit disillusioned
because he's like he had worked for
newspapers his whole life I mean he
actually started going to college for a
journalism he didn't finish because he
got a job as a journalist and just kind
of like worked his way up in that way
but um
he said prior to him writing the dark
Alliance series he's like I would have
defended
um you know the the profession like the
you know newspaper
industry like to anybody that would
listen uh you know and and journalism
being like a really Noble profession and
everything but he's like I you know and
he's like I had always had like an easy
time I had won prizes and stuff and I
thought it was just because I was [__]
hot at my job or whatever but it turns
out
um that the second you write something
that people in power don't want you
don't want anybody to know about
um then they're gonna [__] up your [__]
you know what I mean so uh yeah so so he
kind of uh got a little bit of a eye
opener there
so uh and he actually wrote an article
about this later on that was called The
Mighty Wurlitzer plays on like talking
about uh yellow piano yeah yeah
it's you know he he's like basically you
write about something that they don't
want you to know about and then all of a
sudden like your life is not [__]
worth it
so after he quit the newspaper the San
Jose Mercury News
he actually went and worked as an
investigator for the California State
Legislature
um and as I mentioned earlier like one
of his jobs was investigating like
racial profiling because uh you know at
the time like doing like traffic stops
and stuff like that is like uh so he
talked a lot about racial profiling and
that and you know various other kind of
things and he also did
um you know freelance investigatives
like he worked for Esquire and stuff
like that
um and then he went and worked at the
State assembly's Office of majority
services and got laid off when a new
assembly member came in and in August of
2004 uh he actually ended up working for
the Sacramento news review which is like
an alternative paper like a weekly paper
and uh did investigative writing one of
the last things that he wrote before he
died was
um
it was kind of about how some video
games
were um were used to kind of like
encourage people to like be like recruit
them into the military you know what I
mean yeah like yeah so he uh yeah so he
read an article about that and that was
one of the last major things that he
wrote before he died
now
now here's the thing
so Gary Webb was found dead in his house
in December of 2004.
he had two gunshot wounds in his head
now
Sacramento Sacramento County coroner's
office ruled his death a suicide
even though it's two shots which is
weird that's pretty weird
and it was a with a 38. how do you feel
about that no not good where were the
hits
um the first shot uh was it looked like
he had put the gun to his right ear and
the first shot went through his face and
then the second one went through an
artery
like the first shot came out his left
cheek like it was right here and he
could have survived it right here's the
thing but then like to have the
wherewithal to like shoot again yeah
here here's the thing
I know all about 38 special man [__]
I've had 37 Magnum revolvers and hand
loaded uh a lot of 38 special and 327
loads for it had a Smith Wesson 586 six
inch barrel [__] Target revolver one
of the sweetest [__] revolvers I'm
very familiar with 38 Special
it's not a very energetic load
maybe a little bit less than nine
millimeter I don't know exactly what
projectile he was using or what load
still you would think if you were to put
that up to your ear and pull the trigger
and it didn't kill you because the path
of the bullet just wasn't in a
real critical spot you think it would at
least Knock You Out
see that's what I was thinking yeah I
was like look they said according to the
coroner's report
it said that the gun was behind his
right ear yeah and that the first bullet
exited his left cheek so it went through
his face yeah and then the second one
hit an artery I was sitting there
thinking
it's possible for you to shoot yourself
twice in the head but shooting yourself
in the neck and it going through your
face would you really have the bald like
to do it again unless you did it real
quick
I don't know man that just sounds kind
of weird
to me well the face is not a
critical area well I know that's just
bonus but you would think that I mean
just like the shock of that happening
you would think that what would happen
is that you did that with [__] first
of all just knock you on your ass or
knock you out that's what I was thinking
and you'd lay there
probably die of blood loss but I guess
not in this case if if he survived that
and then you come to a few minutes later
and [__] the pit the Epistles laying
over on the ground and then you crawl
over there and get it
and then take a better shot shooting
yourself the head involves getting it
into the cranial cavity into the brain
all right and dudes have survived that
having a bullet Tunnel right through
their brain yep okay
not a sure thing I mean it's
most likely it kills you but uh you but
it might not yeah which is [__]
horrifying that's horrible um well
that's why some people do things like
jump off a high you know building so man
that that fall on the way down oh no
thanks
I don't want to tell people you know the
best way to do it
probably get [__] demonetized anyway
well yeah I'm sure something like we've
already been
something like a pistol
there's not a lot of energy there
especially 38
anything you know 38 and smaller there's
not a lot of energy there I wouldn't do
it
you want something bigger
and the placement's got to be correct
some of us say well what about
poison
no that's not a good death man you get
real [__] sick yeah no thank you um
there are many Pleasant drugs out there
alcohol being one of them this is you
could you can do it that way yeah
there's weird ways of doing that
um if you know how to run IVs and things
you know something kind of like lethal
injection you know there's a bunch of
different ways that are more pleasant
than that
and Jay and I were talking about some
people that [__] ended themselves
because I heard that even the word that
started with s about ending yourself is
[__] I don't know that you can get
demonetized well they yeah you can
so I I don't know
um
the people that do that think that
they're a burden to other people and
they're going to try to get rid of
themselves
and it'll be better for everybody else
around no it gets worse for them that
you're gone one dude climbed inside a
sleeping bag
shot himself
to keep the mess down
but still his family had to find him
like that and then [__] you know what
I mean
and then you know he's not around to
help pay bills [__] and then they gotta
spend money on [__] dispose enough I
mean no it's not the way to do it
pull your own weight Man fight back
[__]
a lot of times people do that [__] over
problems that are easily solved and had
they just waited it would have [__]
worked itself out anyway
yeah you know
don't do it it's not worth it
yeah well I mean it's easy to say that
but it's like you know some people don't
think that I'd have to I'd have to see
what this crime scene looked like or if
it was a crime scene
okay A lot of times if an intelligence
agency is going to do this
it's four or five guys
who see probably maybe know the guy or
there's some kind of connection they
talk their way in they could be dressed
as police
and they grab him one on each limb
and they do something to him to make it
look like he did it to himself that's
how you do it
that includes throwing somebody out of
Windows they do that too
but usually involves ropes
easy
four or five guys I kind of feel like
throwing somebody out a window or off a
cliff would probably be the better
proposition back in the 20s and the 30s
throwing somebody out off of something
was the way to do it but but back then
there weren't very many security cameras
that's true so you had you have to get
the team to the Target you got to be
sneaky you have to get the team to the
Target if you find somebody who's been
at the end of swinging from the end of
the rope in a wooded area no no that's a
[__] intelligence agency that did
that or an organ an organization because
they had to do it in the wooded area No
cameras
see but a person who's going to do that
themselves usually doesn't care about
the cameras
so they do it in the luxury of their own
little apartment
you know in the privacy of their own
apartment
so if it's very situational
part of the thing of intelligence agency
is that is that they are all have law
enforcement training and they all
understand
about how indictments happen and they
understand police investigative
techniques
so the mission always is in a performed
in a way that foils investigation
you know
outside is the best
that helps
there's just less to work with
so what happened with this guy I give it
50 50. maybe he did do that to himself
well okay so let me say I'm I'm not
really sure where I come down on this
because
one I thought it was pretty weird that
it's like most people don't usually like
shoot themselves in the head twice it's
not impossible
um it you know it has been done before
it's unlikely yeah
however I will note
that um
Gary Webb's family including his ex-wife
because oh by the way like all the [__]
that happened like the whole shitstorm
that happened like after the series came
out and him getting fired and all that
uh that you know caused his marriage to
break up and stuff like that as well
because he was married he had like three
kids
um his ex-wife said that she did not
believe he had been murdered she thought
that he had killed himself because
um well he hadn't really been able to
get another job at a paper his career
wasn't ruined ruined but I mean because
he was still doing investigative
reporting but not to the extent that he
had been before like he was just working
for smaller outfits and so I think he
was depressed about that and also he
wasn't making that much money and he
couldn't what I heard from sources you
know various sources around the internet
was that he could not afford to pay his
mortgage on his house anymore so he had
to sell his house and he actually ended
up shooting himself on the day he was
supposed to move out of the house okay
so yeah the situation
now now that I know that the situation
does kind of lean towards yeah yeah and
his ex-wife said um you know Susan Bell
her name is and she did say that he'd
been depressed for a long time which
like I said you know the poor [__]
guy you can't you know it's very
understandable
um because
you know he wrote this article and he
was just trying to get information out
there that he thought was interesting
and that people needed to know and it
basically kind of ruined his life I mean
you know which that's how it happens
sometimes so it's entirely possible so
do I think that he was murdered
I don't know it's possible
um and a lot of people do still believe
that
um because I saw like some other uh you
know articles and like blog posts and
stuff like that where some people
thought that that yeah like maybe the
CIA allegedly
um did kind of like
do that and like make it look like he
had killed himself I don't know though I
mean they do some shady [__] uh you know
that's for sure but
I don't know it and the thing about it
is that it had been
at the point that he died
it had been eight years since the
original series
um you know and six years I think since
his book had come out
right yeah sort of like six years since
his book had come out so you'd think
that if they were gonna do it they
wouldn't have waited that long I don't
know but
and and I'm not saying that I don't
think that like the CIA was doing what
he said that they were doing because I
absolutely think they were and as I said
I think they did come out later and they
didn't say yeah we did that [__] they
did kind of say though that well some of
the allegations he made were true and
they did know about that [__] and they
did like protect a lot of the drug
dealers another thing about the two
shots
to the Head thing
in light of everything else now that I
think about it
if a pro team went in there to liquidate
that dude
we've only done it in one shot the the
placement would have been perfect
if you got guys holding him down and
everything
yeah you'd think why would they want why
would they want to introduce uncertainty
they would go right where to place
because the coroner's office said that
they got a [__] ton of phone calls when
people like because people thought he'd
been murdered right you know what I mean
because they're like what the [__]
what's up with two shots you know what I
mean they said they got a whole [__] ton
so people were suspicious yeah a pro
team goes in there and freaking talks to
you they might think that they're cops
or some of you know you might know them
and then boom they grab you by
there's four or five guys there they
grab you by the wrist and the [__]
ankles stretch your ass out you just
can't fight that that many guys you know
uh unless you're [__] supernaturally
big
and then they just [__] hold them
down and just [__] put it right where
it has to go and [__] I think they're
gonna make sure that the angles are
correct how to to kind of fit a
situation where it's you know they might
put him in a chair too you know what I
mean to make it look like he did it in
the chair and then um they're going to
do it like that
they're gonna have friendly people in
the DA's office probably too to say oh
yeah that was suicide you know but maybe
not because if it looks good enough
the police on their own will decide that
yeah that was a suicide
you know
no signs of forced entry
doors were locked that kind of thing
yeah
so
um so basically after he died
um you know there was kind of in 2006 uh
there was a biography of him that was
written
um that was written by a journalist
named Nick shoe and that was the book
that book in dark Alliance those two
books were what um the movie killed the
messenger was based on which came out in
2014 with Jeremy Renner if you haven't
seen it uh it's about Gary Webb they
it's it's they took some Liberties but I
think it's like um pretty fairly
accurate
so
um basically the guy that read the
biography said that
mainly uh a lot of the stuff that Gary
Webb first reported in the dark Alliance
series
[Music]
um
about the CIA involvement
um then that they had actually later
acknowledged that they had covered up uh
Contra drug trafficking like I said I
don't know if they were directly
directly involved but they for sure knew
about it and were allowing it to happen
and we're protecting kind of the main
players for their own uh reasons so they
did come out in a bit that much but even
people sympathetic to Gary Webb are
basically saying that the original
series maybe was a little overblown
because he did kind of make much of the
fact that this drug ring that he was
talking about which was free Rick Ross
and uh you know Blandon and uh Meneses
which I say wrong every time
um that they were the ones that caused
the whole crack explosion he's like
maybe it was a little more complicated
than that
um and that seems to be like one point
of contention that people
break that maybe that was like
exaggerated that maybe he like
oversimplified like the whole start of
the you know crack epidemic or whatever
and just kind of boiled it down to like
this main drug ring when it really it
was like a lot more complex than that
maybe and he didn't outright make this
statement but I think that a lot
particularly in South Central and uh in
the black community a lot of people do
believe there that the CIA were
purposefully like I said flooding the
streets with uh crack which I don't
think is the case they were just selling
crack and that's what was ending up
right and that's where there was a yeah
and like I said they didn't particularly
care about like the repercussions of
what they were doing they just needed
the money to you know fund their their
[__] uh and they didn't really give a
[__] about all of the Fallout from it so
you know which is bad enough for
Christ's sake uh but
uh like I said I don't really blame
people for thinking the CIA was doing
that deliberately because that does
sound like some [__] they would do but
um I don't necessarily think they were
doing it
went to where the device was and to the
clientele that could afford it
yeah I mean during that time
upper income people would weren't
smoking crack they were snorting coke
yeah because they could afford the good
stuff lower income is going to go now in
that day and age had been [__] you
know [__] the black neighborhoods in
L.A yeah
yeah yeah I mean they they found
you know an open market pretty much yeah
and they made a lot of money it's a
perfect it's the perfect illegal drug to
make money off of because it doesn't
last very long and it's cheap cheap
buy-in and it's repeated and like I said
and it's super addictive it's super
addictive so you know you pay 10 20 for
one rock and then it's like awesome but
then it wears off like really really
quickly and you need another one and
it's an amphetamine for some reason you
know something that's an upper and for
some reason the African-American
Community likes those they never
psychedelics never caught on with them
white people like psychedelics they'll
buy acid and [__] [__] masculine and
peyote
black people don't like those for some
reason not if it's cultural or if it's
biological it could be but they they're
going to go for some kind of an
amphetamine
I don't think it was intended
based on what you're saying probably not
it's just that they knew that that was
addictive
and then if you got it inside the United
States and it didn't last long so it was
it didn't last long it was addictive and
it was cheap buy-in if you got it inside
the borders of the United States you
make a lot of money and they did they
did yeah they were right make a lot of
you know [__] black funding
untraceable money that's what they
needed
yeah and that's what like I said that's
what people are mad about because they
were using it to fund The Contours about
well among other things they funded
otherwise too much it rolled it it
rolled into
lower income African-American
neighborhoods and that's where it did
its job I don't think it intended it but
that's where it went
and it kind of like I said it kind of uh
[__] up a whole lot of stuff there and
like that and the media focused in on it
which really tainted its
reputation and it became a black drug
known as a black girl white people
wouldn't touch it
they take LSD they'd snort cocaine but
they wouldn't take they wouldn't snort
crack I remember or wouldn't smoke crack
I remember
some people did
people that liked cocaine and couldn't
afford cocaine would do it but it just
didn't take off in the in the white
Market
not as much no not as much to say LSD
and Tweed and I kind of feel like the
big thing nowadays is like meth and
Rural America that's kind of like the
big thing meth and oxy like all those
yeah that prescription drugs that's
biker crack biker crack yeah you it
lasts a lot longer [__] your teeth up
though
I can't stand amphetamines that just I
just don't like them
I don't I don't think that I would be
too into that I like hallucinogens yeah
those are the reasons make you
hallucinate like [__] drinking is fun
yeah hallucinogens yeah yeah
um I I do not need to be any more
nervous or amped up or anything like
that than I already am I would be a
[__] rage monster at all times I
would just not be a good time for anyone
I need I need [__] that like will make
me chill out and relax because I can't
so I don't I don't need anything that's
gonna like make me all [__] Spazzy
all the time Jesus Christ
but yeah so uh so yeah as I mentioned uh
Kill the Messenger is the movie 2014
also
um there is a TV series which I've heard
of but I've never seen and it's called
snowfall and um it's set in LA in 1983
and it's kind of about this it's like a
well it's about the first it's not about
Gary Webb specifically because it's set
like much earlier than the article came
out but it's kind of about
the early days of like the crack
epidemic and it does
kind of go into that narrative
um where it has like a CIA operative
character and stuff like that so they so
they are acknowledging that they knew
that all that [__] must have missed the
show season so the CIA did what they
were selling crack to do it
no so the CIA was swapping guns for
crack on the streets of LA but they
weren't the only ones no that's not what
it was
the CIA was selling well not the CIA the
CIA funded crack sales inside the United
States so they could get black funding
to buy weapons and Stinger missiles and
[__] like that and give them to them did
a contrast yeah
yeah they said all that [__] yeah
yeah Ben said I came in late sorry yeah
Ben said weren't they swapping some of
the drugs for rifles which they were
then selling or offloading in Mexico to
undermine The Mexican government or
something no no I don't know about that
I mean maybe no again that sounds like a
Mexican drug cartels use people here
inside the United States to buy weapons
and SM and then they put them in a
pipeline just just to get them smuggled
back into Mexico
a lot of the Mexican cartels are
equipped with American civilian AR-15s
or AK-47s because that that's an easy
way to get them
um
they kind of banned guns in Mexico I
think in the 70s although they tried to
open them back up for civilian purpose
Purchase mostly things like pistols
because damn sure the Mexican cops won't
help you against the cartels I've seen
I've had guys in Mexico send me videos
of them setting dudes off fire in front
of cops the cops running
okay because the cartels run Mexico not
the cops not really
because the cartels work for the police
work for political
powerful political
people inside Mexico why why would you
want to worry if you're a politician why
would you depend upon
a justice system or or a government
system to secure your power it's too
unwieldedly it's too weak you have to
follow rules what's better is to be in a
government
make a bunch of money on the side in in
the drug trade and use them to hire
cartel
uh [__] Narco armies to attack enemy
politicians and keep people in line and
make more money there's no money in the
government really anymore the money is
in in Mexico the money's in those
cartels
because they run it
I mean they'll take a judge and boil him
alive and pour them out in front of the
[__] courtroom steps okay those are
the kind of guys you want working for
you they'll do anything you tell them to
they just spread horror throughout the
society
cops are afraid to arrest them because
not only they go after that cop they'll
go after that cop's family
is uh you know it's not terrorism it's
beyond that it's horrorism it's like
something out of [__] Friday the 13th
worse worse
worse
drugs and gun running is the real
economy of the world
uh well not really sometimes aren't
worth that much
you can get it you could get a uh an
international
AK that's passed through a lot of hands
maybe came from central Africa at one
time been in the [__] 70s or 80s you
can get something like that for about 25
a unit if you buy them in bulk
they're not worth that much
but
it's not just people
sell them to make money for it's
governments buying those things and
giving them to people to overthrow a
government that they don't like
but well the thing about it is that
sadly even though Gary Webb is no longer
with us uh you know and he died a long
time ago I do kind of feel like
nowadays
I I feel like he's seen as like more of
a more of a hero now than he was at the
time you know what I mean yeah like yeah
you know I'm trying to like come at it
from like a balanced point of view and
maybe some of the claims he made were
exaggerated and stuff but
I mean he really did like go down there
and investigate all this stuff and he
you know really brought attention to an
issue which wasn't really being
addressed as I said the two you know AP
reporters had come out with the [__] in
1985 and nobody
followed up on it really I mean yeah
they did a couple investigations but
that never came up with anything so for
him to come out and for it to be like
such a big thing and like put such a
spotlight on it that now I kind of feel
like culturally it's probably common
knowledge uh that the CIA at least knew
what was going on with that [__] and was
involved in it
um so you know you can really thank him
for that because he was kind of the one
that brought attention to it again like
a story that everybody had kind of
forgotten about because you have to
think that by the time he wrote the
story you know that had been you know
that had gone on like a decade before
you know what I mean but he brought new
eyes onto it and
it didn't really end well for him but
you know
I don't think he killed him though
yeah I'm kind of thinking maybe not like
I said it does give me pause yeah but
yeah I was saying when you were in the
bathroom I said that it does seem
strange that I mean if they were gonna
wipe them out you'd think that they
would do it like sooner after because it
had been like six years since the book
had come out like in eight years since
the series they would have done it well
the book came out and the damage was
done so they just said ah [__]
yeah you know what I mean I mean you'd
think that they would and really like
you said it's probably a lot of times
they I think they had successfully
discredited or or you know introduced
enough controversy and question about
his ethics and stuff like that into the
situation that he thought well maybe
everybody will just think that
you know won't really listen to him
anymore it won't take him as seriously
which
kind of is what ended up happening like
I said it's in a ruin ruin his career
but he he wasn't like operating at the
same level as he was before yeah so they
were pretty successful in bringing you
know kind of
putting him down to size I guess and it
ended up [__] him over man like I
guess he couldn't take it which is
really sad
but yeah this was like a really
interesting case so I'm really glad that
you guys
recommended it oh well are you gonna say
bye you just leaving yeah okay
so I guess he's just gonna leave
because he has to go to the bathroom uh
all right so I guess we're gonna wrap it
up because it's getting kind of late and
I have to
go to bed soon because I gotta get up at
five in the morning again
for the long ass drive uh
so yeah
so thanks everybody for dropping by this
evening this was a fascinating topic and
a fascinating discussion as always uh
remember to come by on I guess we're
gonna do the Side Tracks on Friday night
we um we gotta go to Memento Mori on
Friday night but we don't usually we
don't go to that until later so we can
probably do a live stream like before we
go like do a little
uh pre-gaming I guess is what we'll do
and we can hang out with you guys and
talk about [__] like we usually do
on Friday night so that should be fun so
uh yeah have a good rest of your night
you guys and have a good day tomorrow
and we will see you guys again on Friday
night good night